another warrant issued for accused
sexual predator Nathan chasing horse now
this the latest in a series of cases and
investigations into the Dances with
Wolves actor 8 news now investigator
Vanessa Murphy uncovering more about
allegations against him
Brian the latest against Nathan chasing
horse stemming from a case dating back
to 2005 in Montana the allegations that
he sexually assaulted two girls ages 13
and 15. prosecutors declining to
prosecute back then citing a lack of
evidence but his arrest here in southern
Nevada prompted that case to be reopened
chasing horses accused of sexually
assaulting indigenous women and children
for two decades throughout the United
States and Canada and leading a cult
called The Circle A lot has unfolded
over the past two weeks so here's a
timeline January 31st he's arrested on
sexual assault and sex trafficking
charges in North Las Vegas February 2nd
Federal authorities in Canada issue a
warrant for sexual assault February 8th
Federal authorities here file a criminal
complaint for sex crimes against
children February 10 that war orange
issued in Fort Peck tribal court in
Montana
this evening chasing horse remains in
custody in downtown Las Vegas the FBI is
still actively investigating him in
multiple locations authorities in Canada
say more charges are on the way there